with warmer weather here and the
pandemic easing test by an online
pharmacy and lab
show dozens of popular sunscreens and
after sun products contain a chemical
tied to blood cancers benzene it's a
known carcinogen was found in 27 percent
of sprays and lotions tested
that includes products sold by
neutrogena banana boat
and cvs the online pharmacy lab valley
shore has asked the fda now to recall
these products
and investigate the manufacturing
process johnson johnson maker of
neutrogena products told cbs news
benzene is not an ingredient in any of
our personal care products
cvs said quote we are in the process of
reviewing and evaluating information
in and related to val assures petition
and will respond accordingly
and the maker of banana boats said quote
our sun care products undergo rigorous
testing
to ensure safety and quality and meet
all fda
regulations our chief medical
correspondent dr john lapook joins us
now john good morning
benzene is an ingredient that is not
intentionally added
in sunscreen so how is it ending up in
more than a quarter of the sunscreens
that were tested good morning anthony
and it is not an ingredient this is so
important there's no manufacturer that's
intentionally adding it
to the sunscreen product somehow it's in
there as a contaminant it's not clear
how it gets in there
is it one of the ingredients that got
contaminated is it the process of making
the lotion or the after sun uh product
that somehow creates it we're not sure
that's one of the things that the fda is
going to be looking into
how significant are the levels of
benzene that were found in in these
sunscreens
well remember about 27 of the batches
tested had it so 73 percent
i was told there'd be no math but 73
didn't have it for people who are
listening
uh it went from undetectable to about
six parts per million i know it's hard
for people to say what does that mean
a part per million but remember that it
shouldn't be in there really
at all there's no reason for it to be in
there and the suntan lotion
works perfectly fine without it so how
much would someone have to use
for this to possibly affect their health
well this has been described for many
many decades about a hundred years
that benzene is a problem now remember
that the problem with benzene is it can
cause leukemia anemia things like this
and it was described in in factories
where people were inhaling
relatively larger amounts of it in the
air over
many many years so for people out there
who are listening saying
i used suntan lotion for for many years
in the past first of all we don't know
if it was there in the past
we still need the fda to confirm that in
fact it's there at a certain level
and we're going to give these companies
you know the companies gave the
statement saying we don't put it in
as an ingredient and uh we're safe but
we need to have them
do independent testing too and confirm
the findings of vallasher yeah dr lapook
as a former floridian here i do want to
say that
skin cancer is real the calculation is
still in favor of using sunscreen people
should not abandon it however the fda is
looking into
this citizen's petition is what it's
called from valley sure
what more can the fda do
well the first point you made is so
important remember skin cancer kills
thousands of people a year
you need to wear a hat you need to cover
up and also that was sure on
their website has published a list of
the
various products and batch numbers
here's very important
thing listen up there were certain
brands
that depending upon the batch number
had either six parts per million or
didn't have it at
all so if you go to cbsnews.com we'll
have a link to the valueshare website
and people can say okay
what batch do i have or which ones don't
have it at all and maybe
until we get the fda weighing in and
these companies weighing in
we need to have people looking at that
and maybe one thing to do is to say
all right i'm going to make the decision
myself based on the available
information in terms of what the fda can
do
i mean what valesher is saying is we
need to not only have a concentration
but an absolute amount
how much can it have before it starts to
increase the risk significantly
and it shouldn't be left up to sort of a
crowdsourcing function where
a company like valiser which has done
this before with other products
remember zantac they found the ndma and
sunscreen lotion
the hand sanitizer they found benzene a
couple of months ago it shouldn't be a
random process it should be routine it
should be part
of when when these companies make these
products they should be testing them
that's what valueshare is saying
themselves because remember the fda has
a lot of other things to do
they can't be out there testing every
one of these products and they're saying
look these companies should be doing the
testing themselves
and publish it and then that way we can
try to get our
arms around how big of a problem is this
think about the next problem it may be
face lotions or other things we have to
have these companies doing this
routinely yeah still so many questions
for consumers john
thank you very much for a list of the
sunscreen test results go to our website
cbsthismorning.com
you'll also find instructions for
sending val assure samples
of sun products for testing